when you get Barney at 10 or 11
like you described you were like bullied
at school kids called you shitty names
yeah I would have thought just the
opposite like if I knew a kid was on
Barney he'd be like the most popular kid
when I went back to school and by the
time I was old enough to work on Barney
it wasn't cool anymore to watch it wow
so that's why I think I got teased for
it at school
um what would they say to you because to
me I would have been like that girl's on
Barney maybe yeah like wow like she
knows something you know I I don't
remember what they teased me for I just
remember going home from school and my
mom saying like you know what you're
laughing all the way to the bank did you
did you work with the actual Barney guy
in the car was he an or was he a
good no he was so nice you know what's
funny is he was really attractive really
yeah you mean he took off the Barney
head I mean he was attractive yeah and
and I had like a bit of a crush on him
even at a young age but you had to be
like really muscular because the suit
was like right I don't know like
50 to 100 pounds it's like a huge suit
and so he was like ripped and he
happened to have a good looking face wow
what a great story if you would have run
off
foreign